this video is sponsored by longevity
technology
so hello and welcome to the shiki
science show where in this video we are
going to talk all about the circadian
rhythm and its association with aging
so first we'll cover what is the
circadian rhythm and what it does
we'll then look at clock dysfunction and
studies linking this with shorter
lifespan and different diseases in
muscle organisms
and then we'll see how there is
crosstalk between the core clock
components
and the so-called longevity genes and
then lastly we'll have a brief look at
how we can use this information
for so called circadian medicine which
exploits our knowledge of the circadian
rhythms to be able to
improve the efficacy of different
interventions but also to reduce side
effects
so first then what actually is the
circadian rhythm
well as suggested by its name circadian
coming from the latin
about a day circadian rhythms are around
24-hour cycles
that controls daily fluctuations in
behavior physiology
metabolism and cell activity i say the
circadian rhythm
is an evolutionarily conserved mechanism
that enables organisms
to be able to adapt to their surrounding
environments
and to synchronize their internal
processes with environmental timing cues
and this helps to ensure optimal
organismal survival
and so for something to be considered
circadian
it must meet three different criteria
firstly the rhythm must have
an endogenous free running period that
lasts approximately 24 hours
so that's basically the idea that the
circadian rhythms are endogenous they're
within us they're not coming from the
outside
and so in the absence of environmental
cues it would maintain that
around 24 hour periods and that's the
other reason why it's called
circadian and that is not exactly 24
hours
because if you take mice and leave them
in constant conditions
so without light and day transitions
their daily activity advances with each
passing day
because their circadian rhythm is around
23.7 hours
so it's slightly shorter than 24. the
second criteria
is that the rhythms are untrainable and
so that means that they can be reset by
external stimuli
for example if i was able i guess
to be able to travel to america at the
moment i would experience some jet lag
but my body would be able to reset the
circadian rhythm due to entrainment
by the sunlight differences and then
lastly the rhythms must exhibit
temperature compensation
and so that basically means that the
rhythm doesn't increase in speed if it
gets hotter or decrease in speed when it
gets colder
which could be pretty bad if you're
living in the uk and well the reason it
would be bad is because circadian
rhythms
allow organisms to anticipate and
prepare for precise and regular
environmental changes
so it's really useful for us to survive
and that's probably the most important
thing to remember so far
and so the central clock that can be
entrained by changes in sunlight
is found in the hypothalamus in a region
known as the suprachiasmatic nucleus or
sen
and this central clock synchronizes the
peripheral clocks that are found in all
of our other tissues
however these peripheral clocks are also
cell autonomous
they can run these rhythms without
signals from the scn
and how this is achieved in these
different cells is by a very clever
biochemical feedback loop and to
understand how the circadian rhythm is
connected to aging i'll need to cover
the four key components of this feedback
loop
so that everything makes sense so as i
said there are four key components
so-called clock beam r1 cryptochrome and
periods
and so clock and beam r1 are both
transcription factors
they bind to dna and regulate the
expression of different genes
and they do this by dimerizing them
together and binding dna
out of the different genes that they
upregulate
two of them are cryptochromine periods
and so cryptochrome and periods get
expressed and translated in the
cytoplasm
but then they come back into the nucleus
where together those two can demonize
and
interact and repress the activity of
clock and beam r1
and so by repressing the activity of
clock and beam r1
they also repress their own gene
expression and so if they're not being
expressed then you remove that negative
repression on clock and bmi one and so
you can see that there's this negative
feedback loop
and the timing of which this negative
feedback
loop occurs enables this 24-hour cycle
to occur
and well it's a little bit well quite a
bit more complicated than that
but it should be enough for you to
follow the rest of the video
and understand how the circadian rhythm
is connected to aging
and so the first observations are the
fact that circadian rhythms have been
shown to decrease in amplitude with
normal aging
and at times also exhibit a shift in
phase
and has also been shown that mismatches
between internal clocks and daily
changes in the environment
is detrimental to survival and this has
been shown experimentally in mice
as mice with free running periods of
around 24 hours
live 20 longer than mice whose periods
deviate
significantly from 24 hours moreover
myself are deficient
in one of the core clock components
female 1 not only lives shorter but also
seem to age faster
and show features such as sarcopenia
cataracts and
impaired hair growth and so that's from
the genetic level
but also manipulating the environmental
light and dark hues can also influence
lifespan in mice
as when mice were artificially exposed
to a short date or four hours of light
four hours of dark as compared to
the 12 hour light 12 hour dark it
reduced the lifespan of the mice
so these studies reinforce a clear
connection between circadian dysfunction
and aging
and this was further reinforced by a
pretty cool study
that showed that restoration of the
circadian rhythm
extended lifespan for example
transplantation
of the fetal scn into aged animals
increased their ethnicity and extended
their lifespan
supporting their interventions that
restore proper circadian rhythmicity
could have anti-aging potential but how
exactly aging perturbs the function of
internal clocks
remains an open question but one area
where we may get some insight
is from the crosstalk between the clock
components
and the so-called longevity signaling
pathways
and so these signaling pathways includes
maybe some familiar factors
such as mtor saturns amp kinase
and insulin signaling and as suggested
by the wider crosstalk
the interaction seems to go both ways
firstly the genes that encode the
components of these longevity
signaling pathways showing different
tissues
circadian rhythmicity whilst they might
not be rhythmically expressed in all
tissues
the majority of these factors which you
can see nicely in the sugar here
do show some rhythmicity in different
tissues and say for example you can see
a lot of rhythmicity in these different
genes
in the heart and the liver and another
gene that shows rhythmic expression
is the gene nampt or namt and this
encodes an enzyme that converts nmn into
nad plus
with numpt being the rate limiting
enzyme in nadplus biosynthesis
and while nadplus being involved in many
metabolic processes
but also being used as a co-factor for
different enzymes
which i spoke more about in an entire
video on nad plus and aging
and so for these reasons nad plus levels
also oscillates during the day
but the interesting thing is that these
different longevity signaling factors
also feed back onto the core clock
components
firstly amp kinase has been shown to
phosphorylate
kryptochrome and thus is thought to be
involved in the degradation of
cryptogram
which would therefore alleviate the
repression on clock and be melbourne
moreover the nad plus dependent enzyme
so 2n1
directly binds to clock and beam r1 and
rhythmically
deactivates them so removes an acetal
group from them
and also promotes degradation of periods
i'd say this also helps to
maintain a robust circadian rhythm and
so these are just a couple of ways
of the growing expanding knowledge of
how these two pathways
crosstalk to each other and so this rate
as interesting questions
therefore about so-called circadian
medicine whether we can exploit this
knowledge to time
interventions such that they have most
bang for their buck so to speak
by having the greatest efficacy whilst
reducing side effects
and so to reiterate three key points
from this video so far
we know that circadian rhythms seem to
decline with age
and we also know that disruption of
circadian rhythms can lead to metabolic
disorders
and that restoring circadian rhythms can
promote health and longevity
also we know that aging-related pathways
oscillate through the day
so it would seem that there could be
some logic to identifying strategies
that can enhance the circadian rhythm
and or have
implications for the time of day when
interventions are taken
now this is not necessarily going to be
trivial to achieve
mainly because there are other
considerations to take into account
firstly this includes the
pharmacokinetics of the drugs
so that's how they're metabolized by the
body secondly
tissue-specific pathways on top of the
circadian rhythm
could also implicate how the drugs are
processed and then lastly there could be
potential sex-dependent differences
and also other unknown factors so what
additional information would we need to
be
able to address and act upon some of
this information
well like how you can get an epigenetic
test
that looks at dna methylation patterns
to give you a kind of biological age
it would also be kind of interesting to
have measurements of a so-called
physiological time which builds upon the
point that
in the 24-hour cycle there's going to be
a specific
constellation of rhythmic genes being
expressed and then you can use that
information
to tell the kind of physiological time
from a single sample
to know whereabouts in the 24 hour
rhythm you are
and then this could be used to improve
diagnosis of circadian disorders
but also optimize the delivery time of
therapeutic treatments
and interestingly there's already been
some work looking into this
for example there's one algorithm that's
been developed called time
signature that can infer circadian time
from gene expression in human blood
and there's also a preprint for
something called time teller
again using transcriptomic data and so i
think all of this work is pretty cool
especially as there is so much you can
infer from data especially if you have
multiple time points
and obviously how scalable these
approaches will be will depend on what
kind of measurements are needed and
where those measurements can be taken
from
if it's from blood samples from cheek
swabs or from hair samples
as also that all depends on how many
time points you can get and also the
more time points you get for something
like the circadian rhythm that could be
even more
beneficial as she could also then
include things like the amplitudes and
phase shifts
in the algorithms but another thing to
take into account
into these so-called physiological time
signatures
is that they may only tell you about
dysfunction in local tissue but not
whole body synchronization
but all in all these are definitely
steps in the right direction
and with further understanding of the
molecular underpinnings
and the entrainment of circadian clocks
and different tissues
could definitely help identify further
anti-aging interventions
which could be especially important for
those more at risk such as shift workers
so with that i'd like to thank the
sponsor for this week's video longevity
technology for which i'm very grateful
longevity technology delivers high
quality daily news and insights on
research investments and technologies
that extend health span and lifespan
find the link to their website in the
description
so i hope you've learned something in
this video and more about circadian
rhythms
so i'd just like to say thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening